hi everyone I'm mang and welcome to this
fantastic video in support Vector
Machine svm by simply learn but before
we begin if you enjoy watching these
videos and find them interesting
subscribe to our Channel as we bring you
the best videos daily also hit the Bell
icon to never miss any updates from
Simply learn and just a quick info for
you if you want to upscale yourself
master artificial intelligent and
machine learning skills and learn your
dream job or grow in your career then
you must explore simply learns cohort of
various Ai and ml programs simply learn
offers various certification and
postgraduate programs in collaboration
with some of the world's leading
universities like Barton Purdue ctech it
khur and many more through our courses
you will gain knowledge and work ready
expertise in skills like generative AI
promter engineering explainable AI
machine learning algorithms and over a
dozen others and that's not all you you
also get the opportunity to work on
multiple projects and learn from
industry experts working in top typ
product companies and academicians from
top universities after completing these
courses thousands of Learners have
transitioned into an AI or ml role as a
fresher or moved on to a higher ping job
role and profile if you are passionate
about making your career in this field
then make sure to check out the link in
the pin comment and description box to
find an a ml program that fits your
experience and areas of interest and now
over to our training experts we're going
to be classifying men and women and
we're going to start with a set of
people with a different height and a
different weight and to make this work
we'll have to have a sample data set of
female where you have their height and
weight 174 65 174 88 and so on and we'll
need a sample data set of the male they
have a height 179 90 180 to 80 and so on
let's go ahead and put this on a graph
so you have a nice visual so you can see
here we have two groups based on the
height versus the weight and and on the
left side we're going to have the women
on the right side we're going to have
the men now if we're going to create a
classifier let's add a new data point
and figure out if it's male or female so
before we can do that we need to split
our data first we can split our data by
choosing any of these lines in this case
we drawn two lines through the data in
the middle that separates the men from
the women but to predict the gender of a
new data point we should split the data
in the best possible way and we say the
best possible way because this line has
a maximum space that separates the two
classes here you can see there's a clear
split between the two different classes
and in this one there's not so much a
clear split this doesn't have the
maximum space that separates the two
that is why this line best splits the
data we don't want to just do this by
eyeballing it and before we go further
we need to add some technical terms to
this we can also say that the distance
between the points and the line should
be as far as possible in technical terms
we can say the distance between the
support vector and the hyperplane should
be as far as possible and this is where
the support vectors are the extreme
points in the data set and if you look
at this data set they have circled two
points which seem to be right on the
outskirts of the women and one on the
outskirts of the men and Hyper plane has
a maximum distance to the support
vectors of any class now you'll see the
line down the middle and we call this
the hyper plane because when you're
dealing with multiple Dimensions it's
really not just a line but a plane of
intersections and you can see here where
the support vectors have been drawn in
dash lines the math behind this is very
simple we take D+ the shortest distance
to the closest positive point which
would be on the Min side and D minus is
the shortest distance to the closest
negative point which is on the women's
side the sum of D+ and D minus is called
the distance margin or the distance
between the two support vectors that are
shown in the dash lines and then by
finding the largest distance margin we
can get the optimum op imal hyperplane
once we've created an optimal hyperplane
we can easily see which side the new
data fits in and based on the hyperplane
we can say the new data point belongs to
the male gender hopefully that's clear
how that works on a visual level as a
data scientist you should also be asking
what happens if the hyper plane is not
optimal if we select a hyperplane having
low margin then there is a high chance
of misclassification this particular svm
model the one we discussed so far is
also called or referred to as the L s VM
so far so clear but a question should be
coming up we have our sample data set
but instead of looking like this what if
it looked like this where we have two
sets of data but one of them occurs in
the middle of another set you can see
here where we have the blue and the
yellow and then blue again on the other
side of our data line in this data set
we can't use a hyper plane so when you
see data like this it's necessary to
move away from a ond view of the data to
a two-dimensional view of the data and
for the transformation we use what's
called a kernel function the kernel
function will take the 1D input and
transfer it to a two-dimensional output
as you can see in this picture here the
1D when transferred to a two-dimensional
makes it very easy to draw a line
between the two data sets what if we
make it even more complicated how do we
perform an svm for this type of data set
here you can see we have a
two-dimensional data set where the data
is in the middle surrounded by the green
data on the outside in this case we're
going to segregate the two classes we
have our sample data set and if you draw
a line through it's obviously not an
optimal hyper plane in there so to do
that we need to transfer the 2D to a 3D
array and when you translate it into a
three-dimensional array using the kernel
you can see where you can place a hyper
plane right through it and easily split
the data before we start looking at a
programming example and dive into the
script let's look at the advantage of
the support Vector machine we'll start
with high dimensional input space or
sometimes referred to as the curse of
dimensionality we looked at earlier one
dimension two Dimension three dimension
when you get to a thousand dimensions a
lot of problems start occurring with
most algorithms that have to be adjusted
for the svm automatically does that in
high dimensional space one of the high
dimensional space one high dimensional
space that we work on is sparse document
vectors this is where we tokenize a
words and documents so we can run our
machine learning algorithms over them
I've seen ones get as high as 2.4
million different tokens that's a lot of
vectors to look at and finally we have
regularization parameter the
regularization parameter or lamba is a
parameter that helps figure out whether
we're going to have a bias or
overfitting of the data whether it's
going to be overfitted to very specific
instance or it's going to be biased to a
high or low value with the svm it
naturally avoids the overfitting and
bias problems that we see in many other
algorithms these three advantages of the
support Vector machine make it a very
powerful tool to add to your rep
repertoire of machine learning tools now
we did promise you a Ed Case Study we're
actually going to dive into some Python
Programming so here we are in the
Anaconda python notebook or anaconda
Jupiter notebook with python we're using
Python 3 I believe this is 3.5 but it
should be work in any of your 3x
versions and uh you'd have to look at
the sklearn and make sure if you're
using a 2X version or an earlier version
let's go and put our code in there and
one of the things I like about the
Jupiter notebook is I can go up to view
and I'm going to go ahead and toggle the
line numbers on to make it a little bit
easier to talk about and we can even
increase the size because this is edited
in in this case I'm using Google Chrome
Explorer and that's how it opens up for
the editor although anyone any like I
said any editor will work now the first
step is going to be our Imports and
we're going to import four different
parts the first two I want you to look
at are line one and line two are numpy
as NP and matplot library. pyplot as PLT
now these are very standardized Imports
when you're doing work the first one is
the numbers python we need that because
part of the platform we're using uses
app for the numpy array and I'll talk
about that in a minute so you can
understand why we want to use a numpy
array versus a standard python array and
normally it's pretty standard setup to
use NP for numpy the map plot library is
how we're going to view our data so this
has uh you do need the NP for the SK
learn module but the map plot library is
purely for our use for visualization and
so you really don't need that for the
svm but we're going to put it there so
you have a nice visual aid and we can
show you what it looks like that's
really important at the end when you
finish everything so you have a nice
display for everybody to look at and
then finally we're going to I'm going to
jump one ahead to line number four
that's the SK learn. dat sets. samples
generator import make blobs and I told
you that we were going to make up data
and this is a tool that's in the SK
learn and makeup data I personally don't
want to go to the zoo get in trouble for
jumping over the fence and probably get
eaten by the crocodiles or alligators as
I work on measuring their snouts and
width and length instead we're just
going to make up some data and that's
what that make blobs is It's a Wonderful
tool if you're ready to test your your
uh setup and you're not sure about what
data you're going to put in there you
can create this blob and it makes it
real easy to use and finally we have our
actual svm the sklearn import svm on
line three so that covers all our
Imports we're going to create remember I
used the make blobs to create data and
we're going to create a capital X and a
lowercase y equals make blobs in samples
equals 40 so we're going to make 40
lines of data it's going to have two
centers with a random State equals 20 so
each each each group's going to have 20
different pieces of data in it and the
way that looks is that we'll have under
X um an XY plane so I have two numbers
under X and Y will be zero or one that's
the two different centers so we have yes
or no in this case alligator or
crocodile that's what that represents
and then I told you that the the actual
SK learner the svm is in two lines of
code and we see it right here with clf
equals svm do SVC kernel equals linear
and I set c equal to one although in
this example since we are not uh
regularizing the data since we want it
to be very clear and easy to see I went
ahead you can set it to a thousand a lot
of times when you're not doing that but
for this thing linear because it's a
very simple linear example we only have
the two dimensions and it'll be a nice
linear hyper plane will'll be a nice
linear line instead of a full plane so
we're not dealing with a huge amount of
data and then all we have to do is do
cf. fit X comma Y and that's it clf has
been created and then we're going to go
ahead and display it and I'm going to
talk about this display here in just a
second but let me go ahead and run this
code and this is what we've done is
we've created two blobs you'll see the
blue on the side and then kind of an
orangish uh on the other side that's our
two sets of data they represent one
represents crocodiles and one represents
alligators and then we have our
measurements in this case we have like
the uh width and length of the snout and
I did say I was going to come up here
and talk just a little bit about our
plot and you'll see PLT that's what we
imported we're going to do a scatter
plot that means we're just putting dots
on there and then look at this notation
I have the capital x and then in
brackets I have a colon comma zero
that's from numpy if you did that in a
regular array you'll get an error in a
python array you have to have that in a
numpy array it turns out that our make
blobs returns a numpy array and this
notation is great because what it means
is the first part is the colon means
we're going to do all the rows that's
all the data in our blob we created
under capital x and then the second part
has a comma zero we're only going to
take the first value and then if you
notice we do the same thing but we're
going to take the second value remember
we always start with zero and then one
so we have column zero and column one
and you can look at this as our XY plots
the first one is the X plot and the
second one is the Y plot so the first
one is on the bottom 0 2 4 6 8 and 10
and then the second one X of the one is
the 4 5 6 7 8 910 going up the left hand
side s equal 30 is just the size of the
dot so we can see them instead real tiny
dots and then cmap equals plt.com paired
and you'll also see the C equals y
That's the color we're using two colors
01 and that's why we get the nice blue
and the two different colors for the
alligator and the crocodile now you can
see here that we did this the actual H
fit was done in two lines of code a lot
of times there'll be a third line where
we regularize the data we set it between
like minus one and one and we reshape it
but for this it's not necessary and it's
also kind of nice cuz you can actually
see what's going on and then if we
wanted to we wanted to actually run a
prediction let's take a look and see
what that looks like and to predict some
new data and we'll show this again as we
get towards the end of digging in deep
you can simply assign your new data in
this case I I am giving it a uh width
and length 34 and a width and length 56
and note that I put the data as a set of
brackets and then I have the brackets
inside and the reason I do that is
because when we're looking at data it's
designed to process a large amount of
data coming in we don't want to just
process one line at a time and so in
this case I'm processing two lines and
then I'm just going to print and you'll
see cf. predict new data so the clf and
the predict part is going to give us an
answer and let's see what that looks
like and you'll see 01 so predicted the
first one the 34 is going to be on the
one side and the 56 is going to be on
the other side so one came out as a
alligator and one came out as a
crocodile now that's pretty short
explanation for the setup but really we
want to dig in and see what going on
behind the scenes and let's see what
that looks like so the next step is to
dig in deep and find out what's going on
behind the scenes and also put that in a
nice pretty graph we're going to spend
more work on this and we did actually
generating the original model and you'll
see here that we go through a few steps
and I'll move this over to our editor in
just a second we come in we create our
original data it's exactly identical to
the first part and I'll explain why we
redid that and show you how not to redo
that and then we're going to go in there
and add in those lines we're going to
see what those lines look like and how
to set those up and finally we're going
to plot all that on here and show it and
you'll get a nice graph with the what we
saw earlier when we were going through
the theory behind this where it shows
the support vectors and the hyper plane
and those are done where you can see the
support vectors as the dash lines and
the solid line which is a hyperplane
let's get that into our Jupiter notebook
before I scroll down to a new line I
want you to notice line 13 it has Plot
show and we're going to talk about that
here in just a second but let's scroll
down to a new line down here and I'm
going to paste that code in and you'll
see that the plot show has moved down
below let's scroll up a little bit and
if you look at the top here of our new
Section 1 2 3 and four is the same code
we had before and let's go back up here
and take a look at that we're going to
fit the values on our svm and then we're
going to plot scatter it and then we're
going to do a plot show so you should be
asking why are we redoing the same code
well when you do the plot show that
blanks out what's in the plot so once
I've done this Plot show I have to
reload that data now we could do this
simply by removing it up here rerunning
it
and then coming down here and then we
wouldn't have to rerun these first four
lines of code now in this it doesn't
matter too much and you'll see the plot
show was down here and then removed
right there on line five I'll go ahead
and just delete that out of there cuz we
don't want to blank out our screen we
want to move on to the next setup so we
can go ahead and just skip the first
four lines cuz we did that before and
let's take a look at the ax equals pl.
GCA now right now we're actually
spending a lot of time just graphing
that's that's all we're doing here okay
so this is how we display a nice graph
with our results and our data ax is very
standard not used variable when you're
talking about PLT and it's just setting
it to that axis the last axes in the PLT
they can get very confusing if you're
working with many different layers of
data on the same graph and this makes it
very easy to reference the ax so this
reference is looking at the PLT that we
created and we already mapped out our
two blobs on and then we want to know
the limits so we want know how big the
graph is we can find out the X limit and
the Y limit simply with the get X limit
and get y limit commands which is part
of our met plplot library and then we're
going to create a grid and you'll see
down here we have we've set the variable
XX equal to np. linespace X limit 0 x
limit 1 comma 30 and we've done the same
thing for the yspace and then we're
going to go in here and we create a mesh
grit and this is a numpy command so
we're back to our numbers python let's
go through what these numpy commands
mean with the line space and the mesh
grid we've taken XX small s XX equals NP
line space and we have our X limit zero
and our X limit one and we're going to
create 30 points on it and we're going
to do the same thing for the y axis now
this has nothing to do with our
evaluation it's uh all we're doing is
we're creating a grid of data and so
we're creating a set of points between
zero and the X limit we're creating 30
points and the same thing with the Y and
then the mesh grid Loops those all
together so it forms a nice grit so if
we were going to do this say between the
limit 0 and 10 and do 10 points we would
have a 0 0 1 1 0 1 02 03 04 to 10 and so
on you can just imagine a point at Each
corner of one of those boxes and the
mesh grid combines them all so we take
the y y and the XX we created and
creates the full grid and we've set that
grid into the Y Y coordinates and the XX
coordinates now remember we're working
with numby and python we like to
separate those we like to have instead
of it being X comma 1 you know X comma Y
and then X2 comma Y 2 and in a next set
of data it would be a column of x's and
a column of y's and that's what we have
here is we have a column of y's we put
it as a capital y y and a column of x's
Capital XX with all those different
points being listed and finally we get
down to the numpy vstack just as we
created those in the mesh grid we're now
going to put them all into one array XY
array now that we've created the stack
of data points we're going to do
something interesting here we're going
to create a value Z and the Z equals the
clf that's our uh that's our support
Vector machine we created and we've
already trained and we have a DOT
decision function and we're going to put
the XY in there so here we have all this
data we're going to put that XY in there
that data and we're going to reshape it
and you'll see that we have the xx.
shape in here this literally takes the
XX resets it up connected to the Y and
the Z value lets us know whether it is
the left hand side it's going to
generate three different values the zv
value does and it'll tell us whether
that data is a support Vector to the
left the hyper plane in the middle or
the support Vector to the right so it
generates three different values for
each of those points and those points
have been reshaped so they're right on a
line on those three different lines so
we've set all of our data up we've
labeled it to three different areas and
we've reshaped it and we've just taken
30 points in each direction if you do
the math you have 30 times 30 so that's
900 points of data and we separated
between the three lines and reshaped it
to fit those three lines we can then go
back to our map plot Library where we've
created the ax and we're going to create
a contour and you'll see here we have
Contour Capital XX capital y y these
have been reshaped to fit those lines Z
is the labels so now we have the three
different points with the labels in
there and we can set the colors equals K
and I told you we had three different
labels but we have uh three levels of
data the alpha is just makes it kind of
seethrough so it's only uh 0 five of the
value in there so when we graph it the
data will show up from behind it
wherever the lines go and finally the
line Styles this is where we set the two
support vectors to be dash dash lines
and then a single one is just a straight
line that's what all that setup does and
then finally we take our ax. scap we're
going to go ahead and plot the support
vectors but we've programmed it in there
so that they look nice like the dash
dash line and the dash line on that grid
and you can see here when we do the clf
do support vectors we are looking at
column zero and column 1 and then again
we have the S equal 100 so we're going
to make them larger and the line width
equals 1 face colors equals none let's
take a look and see what that looks like
when we show it and you can see when we
get down to our end result it creates a
really nice graph we have our two
support vectors and dash lines and they
have the near data so you can see those
two points or in this case the Four
Points where those lines nicely cleave
the data and then you have your
hyperplane down the middle which is as
far from the two different points as
possible creating the maximum distance
so you can see that we have our nice
output for the size of the body and the
width of the snout and we've easily
separated the two groups of crocodile
and alligator we have reached the end of
this session and should you need any
assistance PP and resources used in this
session please let us know in the
comment section below and our team of
experts will be happy to help you as
soon as possible until next time thank
you and keep learning stay tuned for
more from Simply learn staying ahead in
your career requires continuous learning
and upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know
more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here